I had a driver I came home from the
airport I got the bags out the gate was
opening and it crunched his door and it
[__] flipped it backwards and so the
door was open the backwards way like it
it like the door opens and the the the
gate was going and it picked the door up
and opened it
[__] and he had to drive home with
the [__] door open the driver and I
was like oh my god dude I'm so sorry I
didn't know I had no idea the gate was
opening and I didn't know the car was
there and he was like it's okay they'll
deal with it bro they the guy just
showed up he had to drive home like this
he had to drive home holding the door
cuz it wouldn't
shut and I was like dude just let me
know if there's anything I need to do
like for the claim or the insurance he's
like it's all covered and then I was
like that's kind of cool you could just
[__] up the cars and like not have any
repercussions you
know you could just basically basically
get a hammer and be like yo thanks for
the lift [__]
po ah [__] dude hey let me know if they
need me he's like oh well it's covered
ah [__] man
sorry just along the door dude I'll see
you next time have that all
fixed I didn't know it worked like that
oh I felt bad dude I felt
bad and then I came home and I was like
oh I feel so bad and I was like I feel
like it's my fault and my wife was like
it kind of was and I was like what dude
don't say that I need you to be
supportive and she was like yeah but
well I got to tell you how it is but
it's like but I was like it isn't really
my fault I was just saying that's you
said it
wouldn't the guy parked too close to the
[__] thing I always want somebody's
fault I always want it to be somebody's
fault
dude God I always want it to be
somebody's fault my wife sometimes is
like you know it's not it's not
somebody's fault sometimes and I'm just
like I'll find out whose it is I'll find
out who's [__] fault it is dude trust
me I'll get to the bottom of it I'm like
Petty Columbo